What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it. I'm here with my
beautiful host Aubrey and we're going to
be talking about tongues. Tongues in the
church. What is tongues? What do you
think of tongues when you hear tongues?
Well,
I have an interesting take on that
because
I grew up in church the whole time and I
did not grow up around the charismatic
movement or anything. So,
it meant to me, I think, what you're
going to be showing us. And so, I'm not
going to burst that bubble.
Okay.
Yeah. I grew up in churches, kind of
different churches, uh, Baptist and then
charismatic, non-denominational
churches. I did grow up around tongues.
By the age of eight or nine, I started
seeing, um, people speaking in tongues
and sometimes there was a translation.
Sometimes there wasn't, but it was a
language that people didn't know. I
mean, nobody nobody heard real audible
words. And people say it was a language
of angels. And it's a it's a gift that
you're speaking kind of to the Holy
Spirit and stuff.
So, we're going to look at that from the
Bible because that's what we want to
talk about on this show. We only we only
want to know what the Bible says or
history or some kind of other evidence,
but we don't want to just go with our
feelings, emotions, traditions, none of
those things. We want to go straight to
the source.
And for this topic, the source is the
word of God. We can't go anywhere else
on this topic. So, let's start with a
video clip because
um I I'm comparing two different things.
And you're going to see in this video
clip, we're going to compare the gift of
tongues in the church and some people in
the New Age movement. And I want you to
think about what are the differences? Is
there any difference? And um yeah, just
check it out. Check out this clip right
here.
And I was guided to come in this place
to do this transmission. This is Leoria
light language and sound activation. And
you will know if this is the message for
you. Many of us had lifetimes together
as a soul group, as a soul family on
Leoa.
Oh, for the time has come to
[Music]
and
What I've seen with my clients in the
past is that some people actually do
give their consent in the dream time uh
you know they're traveling astral
traveling and um may encounter beings
that appear to be something else than
what they really are. And so you might
think you are communicating with some
angelic being or whatever and actually
it's something else.
[Music]
Angelic forces. Angelic reinforcement.
Angelic reinforcement. Angelic
reinforcement.
So I didn't see anything different. It
was comparing new age light language.
This is what they call it.
Mhm.
Versus uh people in the church. And I
think if you, you know, used just audio
and removed any kind of Christianes such
as hallelujah or in Jesus name
and you just heard the speaking back to
back, you would not be able to tell a
difference whatsoever.
And so I'm wondering why why not?
Because God's not the author of confu
confusion. And to me that's confusing
just listening to it. I don't know
what's being said. Um, it sounds like
something that I hear coming from the
new age world. So, that's confusing to
me. Why would this be in the church if
it's in the new age world? And this is
what is called light language.
Um, I'm going to show you a couple
clips, not clips. I'm going to show you
a couple of uh
comments that were on these YouTube
channels of people speaking in light
language. Sorry, the the screenshot's so
blurry. I don't know what happened to
it, but I can make out some of it. And
and one of them says, "I'm not sure how
I found this, but my chest felt super
heavy. Most of most of this them around
14 minutes. Tears. Wow. Powerful. Thank
you." Someone else says, "Why do I feel
like I was a mermaid and this is how I
spoke to people I cared about." Um, and
so there's other ones. The last one
says, "When you start channeling and
guardians, I just burst into tears. Much
love." So, you know, people are saying
that when they hear this newager
speaking in light language that's un
it's not an it's an unknown language.
Mhm.
People are literally getting emotional.
They're saying, "I burst into tears. My
chest felt heavy. Why do I feel like
this was the way I spoke to people I
loved?" So, the reason I'm bringing this
up is because so many people will say,
"No, when I speak in tongues, I feel it.
It can't be of the devil because it
makes me feel so good. And I have these
euphoric feelings and all this.
This is a a misconception that we have
in the Christian church is that Satan
can't make you feel good.
They're like, "He's the he's the author
of destruction. He's only here to see,
kill, and destroy, and he can't make you
feel good." That's a lie. I can take an
ecstasy pill and I can feel really good.
That's not of God,
right?
uh people who are in the new age
movement, they meditate, they channel,
they it's all love and light and and it
changes people's lives. It's not of God.
So, I have something to say on that
because almost everything
in this world that's a counterfeit like
drugs and alcohol and all these things,
they do make you feel good.
Yeah.
They're pleasurable.
So, Satan's always having a pleasurable
counterfeit even if it is tongues.
That's right.
I mean, Yeah.
Yeah. And so that's that's kind of the
go-to answer that most people have is
like, well, Satan counterfeits
everything. And so this is really of
God, but he has a counterfeit that's so
close you can't even tell the
difference. Um, so we're going to look,
we're going to look at what does the
scripture say about tongues? Because
just to let you know, I do believe in
the gift of tongues.
It's in the Bible. The apostles had it.
However,
well, I'm just going to link what I had
just come to mind
on the fact that Satan can give you
pleasure as well. Because when you are
in church and they're playing certain
songs that are way too like,
I don't know, emotional.
Yeah.
It's usually getting your emotions
highrung,
right,
on purpose. It's a mob mentality that
they're invoking with the music.
And it's also counterfeit. That's not
the Holy Spirit,
right?
That is demonic. Yeah. And that's that's
a good example because you can take the
music the instrumentals of a Hill Song
song
which I like that music
but and I know that you know that's
controversial because some of these
people they're not what I'm saying is
the music sounds good to me and and the
words I can feel like I'm singing that
to God and I can get touched and emotion
and even cry and all that stuff and but
the thing I'm saying is you can take the
same soundtrack And you could say,
"Lucifer, you are beautiful." And you
will get goosebumps and you will cry and
you'll get all the same emotions, the
good feeling, because it's the music.
It's the emotion of the music. Music has
emotion to it. You can play the
soundtrack of a horror movie for a
three-year-old kid that's never been
exposed to a horror movie at all, and
they will get fearful. They'll grab
their mother's leg. They're scared
because there's a spirit attached to
certain types of music. In fact, if even
if they don't know English yet.
Yeah. You don't have to even There's no
words.
Exactly. You don't even know have to
understand what's being said,
right? Because a lot of times that's the
that's what people say, too. Music is
based on the lyrics. You can have
Christian metal or you can have satanic
metal.
It just matters what the words are
saying. But metal music, the spirit that
comes with that, the emotion that comes
attached to that sound is rage.
uh it's anger, it's not peace, love,
joy, all these fruits of the spirits.
And so you can't mix and match. You
can't say I love Jesus.
Like that music is making you want to uh
slam dance and bang your head.
And that's not something that you learn
from culture. That's just what the music
makes you do, right?
You you play some pop music and people
just they start moving and grooving with
it.
They don't have to be taught to do that.
That's the music making you move.
Yeah.
So, we're going to go through and look
at some scriptures here, but first I
want to show you that in the New Age
world, they call this star language. So,
what does a star represent in the Bible,
an angel?
Mhm.
In the book of Revelation, it says that
the dragon uh grabbed a third of the
stars and cast them to the earth. Stars
are angels. So this is literally saying
angel language, but remember there's
good and bad angels. So angel angel
language doesn't just mean good
language.
And then the next one says light
language. And you can think, oh, light,
that's good, right? But Lucifer was an
angel of light. That's what his name
literally meant. So light language. And
then down here it says dragon language.
So it seems like it's starting to get
even more in your face that this is
serpent language. This is dragon
language and I just wanted to show that
that's what they call it. But let's look
in Genesis 10:5. It says, "By these were
the isisles of the Gentiles divided in
their lands, everyone after his tongue,
after their families in their nations."
So in the Bible, the word tongues means
language. Mhm.
From Genesis to Revelation. That's Old
Testament always to the New Testament as
you can get. Revelation 14:6, it says to
preach unto them that dwell on the
earth, to every nation and kindred and
tongue and people. So this word tongues
that we we keep hearing and we're trying
to figure out what is this that's in the
church in the Bible, it simply meant
language
because it says every tongue and nation.
And that's what I grew up with. It's not
a gibberish. Yeah.
Or some kind of language of light or
angelic language that you're speaking.
It was actually known that it was
demonic.
Yeah.
Um I grew up knowing that. And so when
tongues is mentioned in the Bible, we
also knew that it meant that you were
endowed by the Holy Spirit all of a
sudden to speak another language to
reach those in the audience that speak
like Arabic. Yeah.
Or Swahili.
And in the Bible, it even has where they
were endowed with the gift all at once.
Yeah. with many of the apostles speaking
at once and it's like translation was
happening in a second with everyone
understanding
and yes and it was understood. So the
gift, a real supernatural gift would be
if I was uh given a sermon somewhere and
like you said some Arabic dude came in
the back and he doesn't know a lick of
English but at the end of the sermon he
says what you said or you know maybe he
can't speak it but a translator tells
him or something that uh what you said
was amazing and I'm like how'd you
understand and he'd be like well I heard
it in my own language and he be like
well I was speaking English
so that'd be a supernatural thing
or you know I've actually heard a story,
a a true story of a pastor that was
going into hospitals every week and he
would go room to room and one day he
went into a room and there was a Spanish
guy, Hispanic guy dying on his deathbed
and this pastor didn't know anything but
English
and he went in there and he was asking
the guy if he knew God and he was, you
know, this dude was about to die and so
he's leading him to the Lord and he died
in front of him. the guy accepted
Christ. He leaded him to the Lord. Led
him to the Lord. And um he told the
nurse to come in and she said, "Did you
know him?" He said, "No, I'm just a
pastor." And she said, "Well, this guy
didn't know a single word of English."
He didn't know any English, but in that
last that dude's final moments, God
gifted him the gift of tongues to be
able to speak to this man in a language
he understood and he led him to the
Lord. That's a true gift. Uhhuh.
standing up in church and saying
that doesn't edify anybody. We're going
to see verses that say exactly that.
And so it seems harsh to say speaking in
gibberish in church is demonic, but it's
it's not biblical. It's not what the
Bible says. And we're going to find out.
Stick with me. We're going to find out
from the scriptures alone exactly what
the gift of tongues is. This isn't just
one example we're giving. So 1
Corinthians 14:2 says, "For he that
speaketh in an unknown tongue," see,
"Oh, it's unknown." "Spaketh not unto
men, but unto God, for no man
understands him." So right here, it
sounds like, well, maybe this is maybe
it's some kind of unknown tongue.
Mysterious language. Yeah.
Yeah. Like an angelic tongue. But but
unknown just means unknown to the people
in the audience or maybe even yourself.
Because if I start speaking Spanish, all
of a sudden, that's an unknown tongue to
me,
right?
If I start, but it says, "Spaketh not
unto men, but unto God." So, here's a
scenario. Let's Let's read this again.
For he that speaketh in an unknown
tongue speaketh not unto men, but unto
God, for no man understands it. So, if I
went into a Hispanic church and nobody
there spoke English and I'm in the back
saying, "Praise God, I love you so
much." They're going to turn around and
look at me and I'm speaking in an
unknown tongue.
Mhm.
Am I speaking to them?
No. Because they don't understand it. It
says I'm speaking to God. Only he
understands.
So,
this we're going to get more context
about this because it actually tells you
don't do that. It says if you're
speaking an unknown tongue, you're
really a distraction in the church.
So 1 Corinthians 14:5 4-5 says, "He that
speaketh in an unknown tongue edifith
himself because nobody else can hear.
Nobody else knows what you're saying. So
you're really only edifying yourself,
right?"
Well, and I think of it, and forgive me
for saying so, but I'm going to be very
candid. That's what we're doing here.
That's right.
When I have heard people speak in
tongues, I do think it's um an ego trip.
They're trying to serve themselves
most of the time because it is it's like
I am
wholly chosen of God and now I'm going
to showcase this.
Yeah. Because when the Bible talks about
giving the gift of tongues, it's it's to
reach the world. But if you're in church
and you're speaking in gibberish in the
back and nobody understands what you're
saying,
you're just showing off somehow. Yeah.
It's not really Who are you really
helping?
Yeah.
So, here it says, "He that speaketh in
an unknown tongue edifith himself, but
he that prophesieth edifith the church."
I would that ye all spake with tongues,
but rather that ye prophesied.
For greater is he that prophesieth than
he that speaketh with tongues, except he
interpret that the church may receive
edifying. So what he's saying is he's
saying, you know what, the gift of
tongues is a great gift, but I'd rather
that you all prophesied. And he's like,
unless there's an interpreter in the
church because if there's an
interpreter, then you're edifying the
church and not yourself.
So basically what Paul is saying is if
you're speaking in gibberish, you're not
edifying anyone but yourself because
nobody understands it. And then it says
in 1 Corinthians 14:9-11, it says,
"Except ye utter by the tongue words
easy to un easy to be understood." These
words that we these gibberish that we
just saw in this clip are not easy to be
understood.
How shall it be known what is spoken?
For ye shall speak into the air. There
are it may be so many kinds of voices in
the world and none of them is without
signification.
Signific signification.
Yep. Signification.
Therefore, if I know not that the
meaning of the voice, I shall be unto
them that speaketh a barbarian, and he
that speaketh shall be a barbarian unto
me. Mhm.
So, he's literally saying, "Look, if
you're speaking something that's uh not
easy to understand, you're just speaking
to the air and you're speaking like a
bunch of voices and you're speaking like
a barbarian.
Can I add something to that that really
just popped into my mind?"
Yeah, please.
Satan is the prince of the air.
Oh, yeah. Exactly. You're speaking in
the air.
Yeah.
And he's the author of confusion.
Yes. And so when we're speaking
something that's unknown like a
barbarian, that's that doesn't edify
anybody. This is from the word of God.
This isn't a personal opinion of ours.
This is why we're talking so candidly.
This show is about learning truth
together. Yeah. We don't have all the
answers. We want to hear from you. If
you got
um you know, some kind of input, put it
in the comments. If you have
recommendations, we want to know them.
We want to talk about topics that people
need answers on and we want to find out
together. We want to study stuff out
together.
Um, I was gonna add to that that I guess
what I was saying is that it seems as
though they're just making a spectacle
of themselves on purpose.
Um, kind of like a humble martyr. How
how do you
a martyr really wouldn't be making a
spectacle of themselves on purpose just
to be praised?
That would be really messed up. So it
kind of sounds like that.
That is
so 1 Corinthians 14:7-19. We're just
continuing. This is all 1 Corinthians
14. And it says, "For thou verily givest
thanks well, but the other is not
edified. I thank my God. I speak with
tongues more than ye all. Yet in the
church, I had rather speak five words
with my understanding than by my voice I
might teach others also than 10,000
words in an unknown tongue.
Yeah.
So notice he's saying, look,
I'd rather speak five words that are
understood than 10,000 and unknown.
That is like nail in the coffin right
there
for anyone that stands up in church and
and speaking like this.
You're really not edifying anybody.
You're not. This isn't what Paul wanted.
Moving on, it continues. It says, "If
any man speak in an unknown tongue, let
it be by two or at most by three, and
that by course, and let one interpret.
But if there be no interpreter, let him
keep silent in the church, and let him
speak to himself and to God." So again,
look, I want to leave this on the screen
so you can read it for yourself. Again,
the scenario, if I stepped in to a
Hispanic church and I'm in the back
saying, "Oh, God is so good and you
change you changed my life."
There's no interpreter in that room.
He's saying, "Keep it to yourself.
You're notifying you're actually a
distraction." And he's saying, "If
there's if there's not a a Spanish or a
English to Spanish translator,
speak to yourself and to God."
I can be back there and I can say, "God,
you're so good." You know, and I and I'm
not distracting. I'm not, you know,
because I'm speaking some unknown
tongue. And where it says, "Let it be by
two or at most by three." That's saying,
you know, sometimes we go to these
events where there's a mixed crowd.
Maybe we go to Guatemala and there's
some that speak Spanish and some that
speak Portuguese and maybe for some
reason there's some that speak French or
something. Let's just say for example,
and if I'm up there giving a
presentation,
it says let them not let them speak by
two or three at the most. So I say
something, the Spanish man translates,
the Portuguese man translates, and then
the French man translates. Don't do
anymore because it's going to take too
long. It already takes, you know, if I
go like I went to Bolivia recently
and all my presentations I had to shrink
them down to like half time because
usually I I expect to have an hour's
worth of time.
But when I say something and I have to
wait for the translator to say exactly
what I said, but in Spanish and then
it's my turn again, that takes half of
my time. Now I only got 30 minutes. So
imagine if there's two or three
translations going on. this is going to
take all day just to get your message
across. So, the Bible is is giving you
guidelines. If you're going to be
speaking in tongues,
have a translator, but don't have more
than two or three at most.
So,
I'll add and
like forgive me for the comparison, but
we see people who are struggling
like on the streets, homeless people
speaking to themselves all the time.
Yeah.
And in my estimation, most of it doesn't
ever make sense. And they are just
speaking gibberish.
Yeah, I've definitely heard that.
Now, how much more do we we we look more
intelligent because usually they're
strung out, unfortunately, on drugs or
they're drunk.
Um, which Satan uses to channel through
you even
Exactly.
as well. But how much more in some ways
kind of in insane or out of your mind do
you look in church doing that?
Yeah.
It looks similar.
Yep. Exactly. You know what would people
on the outside? You're trying to witness
to somebody who doesn't know anything
about the Bible, doesn't know anything
about God or Jesus,
and you're wanting to be a good
representation of Christ. You love them
like Christ. And and then you finally
get them to step foot in your church.
Yeah. And now it looks like this church
is insane because people are just
screaming
and we're just talking about tongues.
But it goes as far as to where people
like ah twitching and barking like dogs
and everything. I've seen all that. It
happens in Kenneth Copelan churches and
Benny Hinn and all that
right
and that is the condundolini spirit.
When you see that
um when people are twitching like that
that's called creas. And this is what
happens when people are practicing
condundolini yoga. They're trying to
they're inviting the serpent from their
base chakra, which is near the tailbone,
and they're inviting it to their crown
chakra. That's the main goal. Inviting
the serpent to your brain. Think about
that with biblical lenses. You're
inviting Satan into your mind. And when
you finally reach that place, the that's
the top, you know?
Yeah. people start getting these
involuntary twitches and kas and they
think that that's a good thing like wow
we finally like I I'm on some new level
and I I talk to entities and ascended
masters and all these things
will you be getting more into that
probably not
okay so I did a study on this
I won't be sharing that but what I came
out understanding is that usually when
you
study like these prophets and apostles
who were in vision.
[Music]
There's a there's a certain um direction
in which someone falls when they are
supposedly speaking in tongues and they
get pushed back.
Oh yeah.
Um they get pushed down,
right? And they convulse and stuff.
Yeah. When the Holy Spirit comes upon
you in the Bible, they fell on their
faces to worship God.
Very good point.
And so
prostrate,
prostrate. And they didn't flail and
they didn't
seize or anything. It was just
majesty and glory. They were humbled.
They were
undone.
Yeah. And I've never seen the Bible say
that somebody got slain in the spirit
unless it was an angel that literally
slew men,
right? and it killed them, right?
And that's not good. Why would we why
would we go to church to get slain
by an angel,
right?
So, this is this just shows you that
Satan is really infiltrated the church.
First, he's twisted all the doctrines.
You got the pre-trip rapture, and you
got all these different things,
denominations, and uh even the sun
Sunday church all started with paganism
when God said, "Remember the Sabbath
day." So, already there's so much
twisted doctrines. And then you invite
speaking in gibberish light language and
then it turns into creas and the
condundolini
and everything and being slain in the
spirit being drunk in the spirit. The
Bible says be not drunk on wine but be
filled with the holy spirit. It doesn't
say be drunk with the holy spirit. Drunk
is bad.
Yeah.
Anytime you find the word drunk in the
Bible it's drunkards will not inherit
the kingdom. you know, this person went
into the holy temple drunk and they
dropped dead. Like drunk is never good
in the Bible.
Whenever you're out of your mind
basically or consciousness,
it's it's really I have to clarify that
because in some people I truly believe
were given visions
and they
probably didn't look like they were home
during that moment,
right? Um, but when you do have flailing
and running around and and swinging off
chandeliers and you got everyone lining
up to do kind of look like mad people.
Yeah.
Mad men.
Um, there's a difference. Do you know
what I mean? Like you have to consider
what's one of the fruits of the spirits.
Selfcontrol.
Self-control.
When you're running around like a like
an animal and barking like a dog and
flailing, that's not self-control.
That's the opposite of self-control.
That's possession.
And you always know them by their
fruits. That's what the Bible tells us,
right?
Yep. The fruits of the spirit.
Yeah.
So peace, joy, love, self-control, all
these things are not being displayed
when it comes to that movement,
right?
But let's get back to the tongues issue
because this is what we really are
talking about.
And so it continues and it says, "For
God is Oh my goodness, it's right here.
I didn't know this is the verse. For God
is not the author of confusion, but of
peace. Yes. As in all churches of the
saints. I've been saying this, God's not
the author of confusion, not even
realizing that it was part of this uh
presentation. I made this presentation a
couple years ago and I forgot that it
was actually in this context. But yeah,
so when God says he's not the author of
confusion,
Paul is say is using that in the context
of tongues
and he's saying, look, if you speak in
an unknown tongues, you're a
distraction. You sound like a barbarian
and you're confusing.
It goes on to say in 1 Corinthians 13:1,
it says, though I speak with the tongue
of men and of angels and have not
charity, I am become a sounding brass
and a tinkling symbol. So this is what
people will say. They'll say, "Look,
it's a tongue of angels." I want to ask
you a question. When an angel came and
spoke to Daniel, did he speak in
gibberish?
No.
And Daniel was like, "Oh, I I understand
it all.
Let me go get an interpreter." Yeah.
Yeah. Guess what? Angels have the gift
of tongues. Yeah.
Because the gift of tongues is speaking
your language. So if that's heaven's
definition of speaking in tongues, then
why not the Bible and why not our
understanding of it,
right? If an angel presented himself to
me, he'd be speaking in English. If a
Bible presents himself to Daniel, he's
speaking in Aramaic or Hebrew. If a
angel presents himself to somebody in
China, he's speaking Chinese because the
angel has the gift of tongues,
right?
The angel is not speaking in gibberish.
So when we get to this right here, I
want I want to show in the concordance.
It says, "Though I speak with the tongue
of men and of angels." And people say,
"Look, I'm speaking with a tongue of
angels."
But what is this word? It's G32. G32
means Greek 32. And if you look in a
concordance, it'll give you the Greek
definition because sometimes our English
translation, we don't have a a good word
or it' be too lengthy or whatever. So we
just for for an example the word that's
hell in the Bible it's really four words
in in Greek and Hebrew it's um gehenna
shiel hades and tarderus those words end
up just being hell in the Bible in the
English Bible
so when you see this word angels let's
look at it in the Greek um G32
and it says angelos and angelos says
says an angel or a messenger and then it
says usage a messenger generally a
supernatural messenger from God an angel
conveying news or behest from God to
men. But then it says
property properly a messenger or
delegate either human or heavenly.
And when you look at this word, when you
look up this word and find out all the
places that it's used in the Bible, you
will actually see that that word is used
for preacher. It actually says, but
it'll say preacher. In the English
Bible, it'll say preacher. But if you
look in the concordance, what word was
that? It's this G32, I think. Yeah, G32.
Angelos. Because that preacher is a
messenger. We're called to be
messengers. And so when it says, "Though
I speak with the tongue of men and of
angelos or messengers,"
Paul is simply saying, "Though I speak
with the tongue of men's or as eloquent
as an angel or as eloquent as a pastor,
as eloquent as somebody who has the gift
of speaking, he's saying, though I speak
with the tongue of men, or if I speak as
eloquent as an angel, if I don't have
love, it's not worth anything." Right?
That was the whole point. It had nothing
to do with,
by the way, there's a tongue of angels
and it's a it's a unknown tongue. Yeah.
To all men, which is gibberish and is
not edifying to anybody was what Paul
saying.
God doesn't speak in mysteries.
Yeah. Exactly.
He speaks to you in a in a known tongue.
In your known tongue.
So Babel in the this is the tower of
Babel in the Bible. And it says the
definition a city in Shinar where the
building of a tower is held in Genesis
to have been halted by the confusion of
tongues. When you talk in gibberish,
you're talking in Babel. And the word
Babel came from the Tower of Babel. It's
what babies talk in. And notice it says
a confusion of sound or voices, a scene
of noise or confusion. So, we're
literally bringing Babel into the
church.
We're bringing confusion, Babel,
uh, unknown tongue, gibberish into the
church. And this is what the Bible says
when you read prophecy, it talks about
come out of Babylon.
Come out of Babylon. That word baby in
there, baby comes from uh not not having
understanding. baby talk. You know,
goooo gaga gibberish is Babel. That's
what babies speak in Babel. And when God
punished that city, he he made a bunch
of different tongues.
He gave them all different tongues. And
now we have all these different tongues
because God created them.
And the gift of tongues is to be able to
speak in each of those tongues,
right?
It's not a it's not an unknown language.
So, Revelation 18:3 and4 says, "For all
nations have drunk of the wine of the
wrath of her fornication, and the kings
of the earth have committed fornication
with her. And the merchants of the earth
are waxed rich through the abundance of
her delicacies. And I heard another
voice from heaven, saying, "Come out of
her, my people, that they may that they
be not partakers of her sins, and that
ye receive not of her plagues." This is
a plea from God, saying, "Look, there
her is a church." When you see that word
her, that's underlined, her is a is a
church. And there's two church, there's
two women in the book of Revelation, the
pure woman and the harlot. And the pure
woman is God's people. Remember the
church is not a building. It's it's a
body of people. And God has his people
which is represented by the pure woman.
And then there's this other
There's this harlot church that has
invited
doctrines of demons into the church.
Confusion. That's why it says drunk.
This harlot is drunk with confusion. But
God is saying, "Look, you may be in that
church. You may be in that church that's
speaking Babel, that's literally
bringing Babylon into the church, but
come out of her." And he's calling them
his people because God has people in all
denominations and all churches. But he's
saying, "In these last days, you must
come out of her because I'm going to
pour my wrath upon the earth, and I
don't want you to partake of those
plagues. Please come out of her, my
people. And so this is God's plea for us
to to escape the wrath to come out of
these false teachings that are literally
doctrines of demons.
Did you have any other things to think?
No.
I hope this was edifying. I hope it made
sense. I hope it was clear because I
wasn't speaking in gibberish. Um, if you
speak another language, I hope that this
is translated by Google and they can be
shared with the world because we want
the message to go out to the ends of the
world. And we want our words to be clear
and understood and not to be gibberish,
not to sound like a barbarian. We want
everyone to be edified. And so, if you
were blessed by this, if it made sense,
give it a thumbs up. Please share this
with people that you know are struggling
with these things. And if you're you're
new to this channel, click subscribe
because we come up with videos like this
all the time. And it's only because of
you that we can even do this. We
actually stepped away and in faith we're
doing what God's called us to do. We're
starting our own ministry. If you would
like to support this ministry, you can
do so by going to some of these um
different digital ways to give. We have
Cash App at Dollarign Candid Truth
Official. We have Vinmo and you can
domikeyjenny
which is my name and at zel you can give
to executebrandgmail.com.
We also have a donate button on
candidtruth.org.
If you click that it'll allow you to
donate to us through PayPal. So we have
many different ways that you can donate.
If you would like to wear a t-shirt with
our logo on it, that helps support us as
well. and we have a Teespring that's
connected on our website.
So, we love you. We thank you for being
with us. We hope that you were blessed
by this and we
uh give us a give us some comments. We
want to know what you think and give us
some more verses. If you think you can
prove that we should talk in gibberish,
give us the verses. We want to get it
from the Bible and the Bible alone.
We love you. God bless and we'll see you
next time on Candid Truth.